Hello. Now, before we go to today's episode, I have some insanely exciting news for you. On Friday, the 4th of September, Dominic and I will be forming live at the South Bank Centre in London. And better yet, we will be doing something completely new, something that no one has ever heard before on the rest is history. The ultimate Victorian adventure. So to give you just a little taste, we will be in Africa in 18, The Emperor of Abyssinia, Theodore II, has kidnapped 59 Europeans and he is holding them hostage after descending into this demented rage because one of his fellow monarchs, Queen Victoria, has declined to answer his letters. I'm not making this up. And the British, after months and months of fruitless waiting, have lost patience and they have sent a military expedition. under General Napier, halfway around the world to save them, an expedition that includes
thousands of mules, loads of elephants, and they've even had to build their own railway across the highlands of Abyssinia or Ethiopia to try to get to his mountain citadel. It is a bonkers story. Yeah, it's absolutely extraordinary, full-blown British imperial epic, full of ludicrous behaviour, mad characters, colossal moustaches, everything that we love on The Rest is History. It is, though I say so myself, a guaranteed classic in the making. So you're probably thinking how can I get a ticket for this extraordinary Victorian adventure? Here is the answer. If you want to get a ticket for this event on Friday, the 4th of September, all you have to do is to go to The Restis History.com.
as simple as that, you maybe have to part with some money, but it will be money very, very, very, very well spent. See you there. And now it was, the news began to reach Rome of the Teutons and the Kimbrey. Initially, the reports detailing the numbers and strength of these invaders seemed fantastical. But it soon became clear that all the rumours were in reality underwere. estimates of the truth. Three hundred thousand warriors were on the march, accompanied by even larger numbers of women
and children, all of them looking for lands and cities in which to settle. Who were these people? From what distant part of the world had they emigrated? It was unclear. For prior to their descent on Gaul and Italy, no one had ever heard of them. The best guess, they were Germans, and had travelled from the lands that border the northern ocean. This supposition derived from various clues. Firstly, their enormous size. Next, the light blue colour of their eyes. And finally, the fact that Kimbrey is a word which in the
language of the Germans means plunderer. That was the Greek historian Plutarch. And he's describing a very chilling and spine-tingling terms. One of the most terrifying moments in Roman history, a migration of barbarians, which by the year 113 BC, had arrived at the gates of Roman Italy. And these people, the Teutons and the Kimbrey, Tom, am I stretching a point to say that effectively they're the Danes? Yeah, Plutuck says that they come from the lands that border the Northern Ocean. And the general thinking is that this was probably Jutland and the regions north of it. I mean, it's a kind of proto-viking invasion, if you like.
And it would have taken them a long time to get from Jutland down to the Alps. So it could well have taken the Toutons and the Kimbrey, anything up to a decade to get there. And if so, for most of that decade, obviously the Romans and the people of Italy had no idea what was approaching them. And it always kind of makes me think of those kind of Hollywood dramas where there's an asteroid hurtling towards planet Earth, or there are scientists experimenting with some zombie mutation in a lab and people are going about their everyday lives, just waiting for this kind of appalling apocalypse to hit them. Yeah. It's December 2019 and you're hearing the first reports from Wuhan. Yes. Of people with people with unusual colds.
And around the breakfast table, people are discussing their summer holidays. Exactly. And so in today's episode, we are going to be looking at what is going on in Rome as this migrationary apocalypse is hurtling towards them. And just to give people a sense of where we are in the history of Rome, we are a century before the age of Augustus. So before the establishment of the rule of the Caesars. And Rome at this point is still a republic.
It is not ruled by. an autocrat. And the star of this episode, the star of the show, is the dominant figure of this period in the kind of the 110s, the 100s BC. And he is a brilliant soldier. He is a superb political operator. And he has emerged seemingly from nowhere to become the city's great popular hero. And this is a man called Gaius Marius. And he is a man whose achievements, whose ambitions over the course of the 110s and the 100s have increasingly put the whole of Rome in his shadow and will continue to do so for several decades after he is a titanic figure in the history of the Roman Republic. Yeah, and we'll be tracing his story, won't we?
So he has this great confrontation, doesn't he, with the Teutons and the Kimbray? But that's merely the beginning of his extraordinary career. Spoiler, he is the guy who is going to see off this apocalyptic threat. He is the kind of the Bruce Willis seeing off the asteroid. Then in 91 BC, when he's considerably older, he plays an important role in one of the most desperate wars that the Romans ever fight. It's not very well known, but it brought Rome almost to the brink. And this was a war that was fought against the Socki, they called them, their comrades in arms. And these were the Italian allies who had been by the side of the Romans. for centuries by this point, and suddenly they erupt and there's this terrible war that rages across Italy. And then most fatefully of all, and escalating gradually throughout the series to an incredibly bloody climax, we have the bitter rivalry between Marius and a younger man who had once been Marius' deputy. And this is a man called Lucius Cornelius Sulla. So I've been looking forward to this since we started the rest of history, because when I was a teenager,
I read a series of books by Colleen McCulloch, I think, he wrote The Thorn Birds. And she wrote this Roman sequence in which the Marius Sulla rivalry played a huge part. It was a brilliant, if you're a teenage boy interested in Rome. You know, this is absolute catnip. And the great thing about them is they seem such archetypes. So Marius, the representation, this is how she portrayed it anyway. Marius was ordinary kind of rough hewn. He was sort of unpolished.
He's the representative of the ordinary, of the ordinary, people and Sulla is decadent and his golden-haired and he's cosmopolitan and sophisticated and he's the representative of the upper classes. And I'm looking forward to finding out if this is absolute Tosh or if this is actually true. And you can tell from their names. So Gaius Marius, he just has the two names. Lucius Cornelius Sulla. If you have three, that's a giveaway. You are from a kind of a higher class background. And Sulla is actually a patrician, which is the kind of the grandest of the grand in Rome. So there is definitely a class animus there. But the two of them, in lots of ways, are not entirely dissimilar. So both of them
are intensely ambitious and both of them are kind of dazzlingly ruthless opportunists. So they are completely worthy rivals. And Dominic, this rivalry, as you were implying, between the self-made man and the patrician, the one-time commander and the one-time subordinate, the guy with the two names and the guy with the three names, this is going to end up shaking the very foundations of Rome's Republic, because it's going to result for the first time ever in a Roman army marching on Rome itself. Then there will be a murderous civil war. Prescription lists will be posted in the heart of the city, and Rome will end up being ruled by a military dictatorship. And this is a crucial turning point in the history of Rome. And it is a crucial turning point in the history of Rome.
and it is a massive waystep on the road that will lead to the final collapse of the Republic and the establishment of the autocracy of the Caesars. So in some ways it anticipates, isn't it, the civil wars between, you know, I don't know, Brutus and Cassius in one hand and Anthony and Octavian on the other. And as you said, it's the first step in this process that leads to the empire. Well, I think more saliently between Pompey and Julius Caesar, and Pompey, we are going to see the young Pompey towards the end of the series. and Marius, as we see, is going to develop links with the family of Julius Caesar.
And so it's a kind of preface to that great Titanic struggle. But it's more than just a story about Rome, isn't it? About Rome as a city, because we're at a point in Rome's history where Rome is a real geopolitical player, and so what happens here matters across the Mediterranean. Yes, absolutely. And this has been signalled in incredibly brutal fashion. A few decades previously in 146 BC, when the Romans had wiped out two of the oldest and most celebrated cities in the whole of the Mediterranean.
And the first of these was a city called Carthage. We did three whole series on the terrible wars that Rome fought against the Carthaginians. It was their old enemy. It was the kind of the great rival superpower in the Western Mediterranean. And those three wars had culminated in the complete annihilation of Carthage. And then in the same year, the Romans wipe out the Greek city of Corinth, which again, I mean, it's one of the most famous cities in Greece. It's a place rich in mythology and culture and history, absolutely obliterated. And this obviously serves as a devastating warning to the Greeks that there's very much a new sheriff in town. You do not want to mess with the Romans. And to be honest, the destruction of these two cities is a shock that reverberates across the Mediterranean. But the there are plenty of people in Rome itself that feel a bit queasy about it, that there are Romans who start saying, well, you know, are we actually the baddies here? And this worries
And the first of these was a city called Carthage. We did three whole series on the terrible wars that Rome fought against the Carthaginians. It was their old enemy. It was the kind of the great rival superpower in the Western Mediterranean. And those three wars had culminated in the complete annihilation of Carthage. And then in the same year, the Romans wipe out the Greek city of Corinth, which again, I mean, it's one of the most famous cities in Greece. It's a place rich in mythology and culture and history, absolutely obliterated. And this obviously serves as a devastating warning to the Greeks that there's very much a new sheriff in town. You do not want to mess with the Romans. And to be honest, the destruction of these two cities is a shock that reverberates across the Mediterranean. But the there are plenty of people in Rome itself that feel a bit queasy about it, that there are Romans who start saying, well, you know, are we actually the baddies here? This worries
them because the conceit of the Romans throughout their rise to superpower status has always been that they are the most moral of people and that everything they do is in self-defense. And if it's not in self-defense, then the gods won't back them. And so the fact that they have this great empire is proof that the gods have been backing them. So in a way they kind of conquer the world in self-defense. And so they don't want to think that they're bad people. They don't want to think that the gods are against them. You talk about them conquering the world.
But actually, have they conquered the world? I mean, their empire territorially, it's not enormous at this point, is it? So just give us a sense of the panorama of Roman power. They have a kind of informal hegemony, I guess, over much of the Mediterranean. But you're right that the formal empire, the sense in which they have provinces, It is at this point still relatively small. So if you think of Rome in the centre of Italy and you go clockwise around the Western Mediterranean. So Sicily, that was Rome's first province.
They had instituted as a province in 241 BC as the result of the first great war that they'd fought against Carthage. So Sicily had been the kind of the prize that they'd taken in that war. Then across the sea from Sicily, you have what's now Tunisia, what the Romans call Africa. this is where Carthage had stood and the Romans have annexed the hinterland of what had been the Carthage's territory in North Africa. Then southern and central Spain, again, the Romans had taken that from Carthage in the Second War, the war that featured Hannibal. And at this point, the Romans are advancing northwards into the kind of the northern reaches of Spain. And then you have the southern strip of Gaul, what the Romans called the Provincia, the province. and this is the Latin word that ultimately gives us the word Provence.
So it's what's now southern France. And so there's no question with Carthage gone, with all these former provinces of Carthage absorbed or new territories conquered, that Rome is undisputed as the great hegemon of the Western Mediterranean. But what is ominous, I think, for people in the Eastern Mediterranean, is that Rome by this point also has a couple of provinces in the eastern half of the of the Mediterranean Sea. And this, of course, is, these are lands that previously had been ruled by Macedonian kings, so the heirs of Alexander the Great. So one of these provinces had been
the former kingdom of Alexander the Great. It's become the Roman province of Macedon in that fateful year 146 that had seen Corinth and Carthage destroyed as well. And across the Aegean from Greece, So what is now the Eegean seaboard of Turkey? There is another province which the Romans call Asia. And this had been the kind of the Greek-ruled kingdom of Pergamum. Pergamum is a Greek city that controlled the kind of, you know, the western half of what's now Turkey. And in 133 BC, its last king, a man called Attalus, he didn't really have an obvious successor. He was nervous at the Romans of what the Romans might do.
And so basically he thought, well, maybe the obvious solution is just to give it to the Romans in my will. And so that's what he does. And it's one of the most spectacular bequests in the whole of history because Pergamum is fabulously rich, quite apart from giving the Romans a tollhold in Asia. And it is, it offers the Romans all kinds of decadent pleasures that they had barely even realized existed until that moment. So everything from celebrity chefs to sex manuals, they're all brought back to Rome, where the elites, of course, think secretly they're brilliant, but lots of them pretend to be very disapproving. And lots of Roman moralists are genuinely disapproving. And I think it's, I guess the closest parallel in modern history would be Puritan American tourists in the Gilded Age going to Paris. Right.
Yeah. The flesh pots of Europe. The flesh pots of Europe. of course bringing them back to the East Coast. Going to the Folly Berger with Toulouseau, or something. Yes, exactly. And so Pliny the Elder, very much friend of the show, when he's writing about this, he sees this whole period from the conquest of Macedon to the granting biatulus of his kingdom
of Pergamum to the Romans as a period that is disastrous for Rome's moral character. So Pliny wrote that the Romans were becoming a people who didn't just admire foreign opulence but had learnt to covet it. And Pliny identifies the appropriation of Asia as a province as having been a particularly disastrous blow to Roman morals. And it is a feature of the way the Romans think about geopolitics and the functioning of their own state. That morals are incredibly important.
Because as we've said, if they're not a moral people, then the gods won't favour them and their empire will collapse. That's a tiny bit like the British, with Indian people. India in the 18th century and the sort of anxiety that great wealth and expansion would bring corruption, you know, which kind of wrapped up with people like Warren Hastings and all these people who came back and built great palaces. And I think it's there with Jefferson and that kind of tradition in America as well, isn't it?
The anxiety about wealth and power about empire. So yes, absolutely. This sense that the very greatness that Rome is winning threatens the moral foundations on which that greatness has been raised. And also, of course, the influx of enormous wealth into Rome contributes to a kind of a growing sense of resentment in the slums of the city, that the rich are getting richer and the poor is getting poorer. And again, this is something with which subsequent periods of history, I mean, people will be completely familiar with it, that influxes of wealth tends to heighten class divisions, divisions in living standards. And the poor in Rome, you know,
are all citizens of a republic. They're meant to be part of a kind of, you know, a common project, raise publica means, kind of things that are shared in common, things that are public. The poor in Rome are increasingly suspicious that the aristocratic class, the nobilase, as they're called in Matin, that they no longer care anything for the mass of their poorer fellow citizens. Metropolitan elites are out of touch. Exactly. And so this is generating a febrile mood in Rome and it's the kind of mood again perhaps not entirely dissimilar to the present day in which an outsider if he has luck if he has talent if he has boldness on his side you know he might be able to prosper he might you know people from from not the obvious backgrounds might be able
to get to the top of the tree might be able to make themselves the masters of the republic And this brings us very neatly, doesn't it, to our protagonist, to Gaius Marius. So Marius is born in 157 BC in Arpenum, which is about 80 miles outside Rome. And is there a British town that would be a nice equivalent for Arpenum, Tom? I guess it's kind of Swindon, basically. Wow, roundabouts. Roundabouts and warehouses. I mean, having said that, Arpenham is actually a kind of very old city,
so perhaps the parallel doesn't exist. exactly hold. But I guess that the people in Rome would view Arpinum as, I don't know, people in W1 might view Swindon. Right. Yeah. As being not exactly the obvious breeding ground of great dominant figures in the state. And actually, Arpenum is a classic example of how the kind of the immediate hinterland around Rome, so Lashem, as it's called, has come to be knitted into the fabric of the Republic and basically kind of turned into the people of Lashem have been turned into Romans. So Arpinum had been conquered back in 305 BC and its people initially had been given a slightly inferior form of Roman citizenship. So the Romans called it Kivitas Senei suffraggio citizenship without, well, without suffrage, without the vote.
They have lots of rights, but they don't have the right to vote for magistrates. But then in 188 BC, Arpinum finally gets the full deal. So citizenship with the right to vote. and that means that the parents of Marius, who belong to the local aristocracy in Arpena, they basically belong to the first generation in the town who can take this for granted, who can feel that they are part of not just the local politics of their own small town, but of the great city 80 miles to the west. This, of course, means that the young Marius growing up in Arpenum,
he's aware of himself as a Roman. but he is also still very much aware of himself as a provincial, that he's in a city where people have not been able to vote for magistrates in Rome, let alone run as magistrates in Rome for very long, only a few decades. And so probably as a boy, he doesn't hold out much prospect for himself, you know, as a future political star, because there is a very deep vein of snobbery in the Roman people, and they may resent the nobilase, the aristocracy,
for their wealth and their sense of superiority. But they do simultaneously love families with strong brand recognition. And I guess, again, if you want an American parallel, it would be like the way people keep voting for Clintons or bushes or whatever. Yeah. But unlike, let's say Bill Clinton, or indeed, I think any of the bushes, Marius is the recipient of an extraordinary omen. Well, he's the subject of an extraordinary omen when he's a little boy.
And Plutarch recorded this, didn't he? Something to do with an eagle. Plutarch has to be said, will always prioritize a fun story over a likely story. He'd be a very good history podcaster. Yeah, he absolutely would. So this is Plutarch. When Marius was still a boy and living out in the country, he caught an eagle's nest in his cloak as it fell from a tree. This nest contained seven baby eagles.
His parents were so surprised by this freak occurrence that they asked a local soothsayer what it portended. And the soothsayer replied that Marius would become the greatest man in. in the world and was destined to hold the consulship no less than seven times. Wow. And of course, Plutarch is writing this sometime after the events after he knew what happened to Maris. A skeptic might say that Plutarch was making this up. But I choose to believe it.
I choose to believe that this happened. Well, just to say that there is, as we will see in due course, evidence that Maris did believe something like this. He did believe that he was destined to have seven consulships. But seven consulships. I know that that is an absolutely extraordinary prediction. And maybe you should explain to the listeners precisely why it's such a mad prediction. It's completely implausible because of the significance that the consulship plays in Rome's Republic.
So every year, two consuls are elected and they wield the powers of the monarchy that had been expelled from Rome back in 509 BC. So the consuls are the magistrates who lead Rome's armies into war, who preside over the Senate and over the elections that are held in the city, and who crucially mediate between the Roman people and the gods. And these powers, of course, are potentially very, very intoxicating. And this is why there are two consuls so that each one can keep a watch on the other. And it's why their term of office is limited to a single year so that they won't have time to. entrenched their power. And for a century now, so as Maris is growing up, it's been a no-no for someone to have more than one consulship. That hadn't always been the case, but it's become kind of institutionalised. And whether this is an official law or whether it's just the pressure of
custom is, I think, unknowable. But it's clearly the case that you're not supposed to have more than one consulship as Marius is growing up. And what makes it even more of a challenge for Marius, you know, any prospect of seven consulships, just having one consulship seems an almost impossible dream, because he is what the Romans called a novice homo, a new man, someone who has no tradition of holding magistrates in his family and particularly consulships. And it's obvious why this would be the case, because Marius is from Arpanum and Arpanum has only just been given the vote. So of course, you know, his family haven't had time to get loads of consulships. And just to emphasize how how mad it is even to dream of having seven consulships. No Roman in history has held seven consulships.
The record is six, seven just seems impossible. All right. Well, we'll see whether he gets there. But let's kick off with Maris's first steps on the ladder. And I guess if you're an ambitious and talented young man from nowhere, from a provincial town, the obvious way to get ahead is through proving yourself in the one thing that the Romans prize more than any other, which is the kind of, you know, the military arena. Because, you know, this is the bedrock of Roman power, isn't it? The army. And this is where Marius is really intending to make his name. Yeah. So if you want to make a name for yourself, what you ideally want is some desperate and hard fought war in which you can go off and be a hero. And fortunately for Marius, in 134 BC, exactly such a war is being fought
in the northeast reaches of Spain. So remember we said that the Romans are pushing northwards into the Iberian peninsula and they have come up against the people of a city called Numantia. And this war has been grinding on for two decades. And the Senate have got absolutely fed up with it. So the Senate is the assembly of the nobles, the kind of the movers and shakers in Rome. And so accordingly they say we need our top man to go and sort this out. And there's no question who the top man in Rome at this point is. It's a guy called Scipio Emilianus, and people who listen to our episode on the destruction of Carthage may remember that he is the general who brings that final war against Carthage to a close and wipes the city out. And it's a measure of how desperate the Senate is to have
Scipio take over this command, that they allow him to have a second consulship. So we said, this is very, very irregular. They really, really need Scipio at the front, though. So they say they kind of turn a blind eye to the irregularity of it. And so, Scipio travels to Spain in command of a vast army. He has 20,000 men, which is roughly four legions, so a very sizable fighting force of Roman citizens. He also has lots of Socki, these Italian allies, who fight alongside the Romans, and also he has auxiliaries. And the Sochi and these auxiliaries come to 40,000 in all. And among the auxiliaries, there are some particularly glamorous and celebrated fighters. And these are horsemen from a region in North Africa, basically it's
Algeria now called Numidia. And the Numidians have been allies of the Romans for almost a century. The alliance had been forged in the war against Hannibal. Originally, the Numidians had been on the side of Hannibal and then they had switched sides. And when Carthage falls, the Neumis Midians have been given a lot of Carthaginian territory as a kind of reward and to cement their status as allies of the Roman people. And the particular contingent of horsemen at Neumantia is led by a very charismatic young Numidian prince called Jugurtha. And he has brought not only cavalry, but also 12 war elephants.
And there is a kind of ancestral relationship between the Numidian royal family and the families of the Scipio's, because Scipio, Afrikanus, the guy who had defeated Hannibal, he'd been great mates with this Numidian king. So there's a kind of sense that, you know, this is a family business. Now, when Scipio travels to Numantia, he takes with him as a junior officer, the young Marius. And Marius does really, really well there. Just a quick question about Marius. So do we have any sense of his appearance, personality, sort of, I don't know, his bearing, his
vibe at this point? I think he's like, if you imagine, Channing Tatum. Wow. He's big. Okay. He's brave. He's physically tough. He loves fighting. He's, in other words, he's a natural soldier. And he's a soldier in the kind of traditional old school way that the Romans love. So he, he despises fancy cooking. He's not interested in celebrity chefs. Okay. He despises snooty manners. He doesn't have a, you know, a kind of expensive education. He loves sleeping on hard ground with his men with only his cloak to cover him. You know, it's all that kind of thing. Right.
So he's very Roman. A Roman in the way that the Romans like to imagine themselves. Yeah. You know, he hasn't been spoiled by all these snooty manners and things and by Greek learning and stuff. He's not a man for a sex manual. Well, we'll maybe come to that in due course. I think at this point he's not a man for a sex manual. He is rough and tough.
and Hardy, and he loves fighting barbarians. And this is, this is everything the Romans want in a kind of a young, upwardly mobile officer. He's also a very strict disciplinarian. And to be honest, the Romans love a strict disciplinarian. They love being whipped into shape. And this is what Maris is very good at. And he fights and kills one of the, the commanders of the Neumantians in hand-to-hand combat. And Scipio, Emilianus is watching this and thinks it's absolutely brilliant. And later that evening, Scipio is with all his officers. And one of them asks him, you know, who do you see as being the coming man? Who among the younger generation is someone to watch?
And Scipio turns to Marius and he touches him on the shoulder very fondly. And he says, perhaps this is the man. And this is a massive thing for Marius. you know, a commendation from the great war hero, Skippio Emilianus, and it marks him out as a man who, you know, deserves well of the Roman people. It's something that can launch a political career. He's a future England captain. That's exactly what he is, isn't he?
He's the batsman who has been anointed by the team captain as the man who's going to carry the fortunes of the nation in the next 10 years. I think that's a very fair comparison. And so in 133 BC, Neumanti Falls, it's all great. Skipio goes back and Marius goes back as well. There is one problem, which is that Skipio dies very shortly afterwards. Had Skipio stuck around, then he would have been the perfect patron. So it is a bit of a blow. But Marius doesn't give up because he's got his battle scars.
He does have this commendation from Skipio, which is a big deal. Because all of these really matter when it comes to elections, particularly if you're an unknown. You know, you need a story to tell. and Marius has a story to tell. And fortunately he does also have an alternative source of patronage to Scipio. And this is one of the very grandest of the noble families, a family that has been serving as the patrons of Marius' family in Arpinum for several generations. And these are the Kikili Matteli.
他确实得到了小西庇阿的赞赏，这可是一件大事。因为在竞选时，所有这些都至关重要，特别是如果你是一个无名小卒的话。你知道，你需要一个故事来讲讲，而马略正好有一个故事可讲。幸运的是，他除了小西庇阿之外，还有另一个赞助人来源。这是最显赫的贵族家庭之一，几代人以来一直担任马略家族在阿尔皮努姆的赞助人。这就是塞奇利·梅特利家族。
And they are at this period probably the top aristocratic dynasty in Rome. They are madly efficient as a dynasty in hoovering up consulships, for instance. So between 123 and 98 BC, no less than seven of them will hold the consulship. I mean, that's an unprecedented success rate for a single family. And they have been the great rivals of the Scipio family. But when Scipio Emilianus dies, the great patriarch of the Mattelli behaves very, very well in exactly the kind of way. Again, that the Romans like to think that their great men should.
在这一时期，他们可能是罗马最顶尖的贵族王朝。作为一个王朝，他们在垄断执政官职位方面效率惊人。例如，在公元前123年至98年之间，他们中竟有七人担任过执政官。我的意思是，对于一个单一家族来说，这是一个空前成功的记录。他们一直是西庇阿家族的死敌。但是当小西庇阿去世时，梅特利家族伟大的大家长表现得非常好，完全符合罗马人希望他们的伟人所应有的那种风范。
So he runs out into the streets, sobbing, tearing his clothes, crying out, the great buttress of the city has fallen, the man who was our bulwark. And he orders his sons to help carry the funeral buyer of Scipio. So in death, there is reconciliation between these two great families. And how is it that Marius can ride both horses? How can he have the patronage of both, if they're rivals? Or is that not a problem? Because the Mattelli are his political patrons and Scipio had been his military patron.
于是他跑到街上，号啕大哭，撕裂衣服，高呼道：城市的伟大支柱已经倒塌，那是我们的堡垒。他命令他的儿子们帮忙抬着西庇阿的葬礼灵床。因此，在死亡面前，这两个伟大家族实现了和解。马略怎么能脚踩两条船呢？如果他们是死敌，他怎么能同时拥有两者的赞助？或者这根本不是问题？因为梅特利家族是他的政治赞助人，而西庇阿曾是他的军事赞助人。
And basically, you know, if you're not a threat to either of them, you can have both of them, I think. So Maris is a, I mean, although we've portrayed him as Channing Tatum as kind of roughhune, he's a smart political operator to line up both of these. Yeah. And the fact that you play the simple rough hume soldier doesn't mean you're stupid. I mean, you may well be playing that part because you know that it appeals. I mean, there's obviously you can't do it unless as a strong element of truth to it, but it doesn't imply that there's not an element of calculation in projecting that image. And again, you know, people will be able to think of people in their own politics, perhaps,
基本上，你知道，如果你对他们两家都不是威胁，我想你就可以同时拥有他们俩。所以马略是个，我的意思是，尽管我们把他刻画得像钱宁·塔图姆那样粗犷，但他是一个精明的政治操盘手，能够把这两方都争取过来。是的。你扮演一个朴实粗犷的士兵，并不意味着你笨。我的意思是，你很可能是因为知道这样受欢迎才扮演那个角色。显然，除非其中有很强的真实成分，否则你是做不到这一点的，但这并不意味着在塑造这种形象时没有经过一番算计。而且话说回来，你知道，人们也许能在自己的政坛中找到这样的人，
who you know, you can draw comparisons with. Yeah. So in Britain, we would talk about the greasy bowl, wouldn't we, about climbing the greasy pole, which Maris clearly is now hoping with their backing, with his war record that he can do. They don't have the same expression, do they? Obviously, what's the expression the Romans have? So they call it the cursus honor, so it's literally the kind of the race track of honors of magistracies. And the racetrack is obviously derived from the Circus Maximus,
你可以从中画出一些类比。是的。所以在英国，我们会谈到“油腻的杆子”，对吧，关于爬上权力的油腻高柱，马略现在显然希望凭借他们的支持和他的战争战绩来做到这一点。他们没有同样的表达，对吧？显然，罗马人的表达是什么？所以他们称之为“晋升阶梯”（cursus honorum），字面意思就是荣誉和官职的赛道。而这个赛道显然源自马克西穆斯竞技场（Circus Maximus），
which is this great public space where all the people of Rome gather. And this racetrack leads from magistracy to magistracy, and the finishing line, of course, is the consulship, which is the top magistracy. But as we've said, this for a novice homo, like Marius, a new man, I mean, it's a big ask. That finishing tape of the consulship is a very long way. So in the immediate present, he has to focus on kind of more junior magistracies. Unfortunately, there is one magistracy in particular which really seems to suit his skill set, because this is a magistracy which requires the man who holds it to defend the interests of the people
这是罗马所有人民聚集的大型公共空间。这条赛道从一个官职通往另一个官职，而终点线当然就是执政官这个最高官职。但正如我们所说，对于像马略这样的新人（novus homo），一个新贵来说，这真是一个巨大的考验。执政官的那个终点线还非常遥远。所以在眼前，他不得不把精力集中在一些更初级的官职上。幸运的是，有一个官职特别符合他的技能组合，因为这是一个要求任职者捍卫人民利益的官职，
against the senatorial elites. And this is perfectly suited to Marius. The problem is that in 119 BC, when Marius decides to run for it, even though that this office is a very potent one, it is also quite a dangerous one to hold. And this office is the Tribune of the PLEBs, of the plebeians, of the people. And it comes with incredible powers. So the Tribune has the veto, very famous. A Tribune can veto any bill that he thinks threatens the interests of the plebs, of the people. He has a right to convene public assemblies, so not the Senate, but gatherings of the general citizenship,
来对抗元老院精英。这非常适合马略。问题在于，在公元前119年，当马略决定竞选时，尽管这个职位非常具有影响力，但担任它也相当危险。这个职位就是平民保民官（Tribune of the Plebs），代表平民，代表人民。它赋予了令人难以置信的权力。因此，保民官拥有否决权，非常著名。保民官可以否决任何他认为威胁到平民和人民利益的法案。他有权召集公民大会，不是元老院，而是普通公民的集会，
and get them to pass bills of his own, say plebiscites. His own person is absolutely inviolate. It is completely forbidden to lay hands on him. And the reason why that's important is obviously is that if the Tribune is passing measures or blocking legislation that is supported by the mass of the aristocracy, he has to be respected. But is he respected. This is the question. So this is the question. So Marius decides that he's going to run for the tribunate in 1119.
并让他们通过他自己的法案，比如公民投票法案。他的人身绝对不可侵犯。绝对禁止对其实施任何暴力。之所以重要，显而易见的是，如果保民官正在通过措施或阻止得到大多数贵族支持的立法，他就必须受到尊重。但他真的受尊重吗？这就是问题所在。所以这就是问题所在。因此，马略决定在公元前119年竞选保民官。
And we've said it's a very potent magistracy. But at this time, it is also a very dangerous one for anyone. to have. Maris has been elected Tribune just two years after one of his predecessors had been murdered. And this, of course, had been a terrible sacrilege. We've said that the person of a Tribune is inviolid. And the death squad that killed this Tribune had been led by a consul. And the corpse of the Tribune had been systematically insulted. The body had been decapitated and the head the skull had been filled with lead to serve as a trophy. So in other words, class war, as Marius is looking to make his way, you know, the first kind of lengths of the cursus andorum, has come to
我们说过这是一个极具影响力的官职。但在当时，对任何人来说，它也是一个非常危险的职位。马略当选保民官时，距离他的前任之一被谋杀仅仅过去两年。当然，这曾是一桩可怕的亵渎。我们说过保民官的人身是不容侵犯的。而杀死这名保民官的行刺暗杀小队是由一名执政官领导的。这名保民官的尸体遭到了系统性的侮辱。尸体被斩首，头骨里被灌满了铅，当作战利品。换句话说，正当马略试图在“晋升阶梯”上迈出最初的步伐时，阶级战争已经降临到了
Rome. And for someone like Marius, who is a man of the people, no real pedigreel background, but very ambitious, this means that the tight rape he's going to have to tread is incredibly treacherous and potentially fatal. So Maris is setting out on this potentially fatal tightrope and the stakes are very high and we'll find out what happens after the break. This episode is brought to you by Amazon. Tom throughout history,
罗马。对于像马略这样出身平民、没有显赫家世背景但野心勃勃的人来说，这意味着他将要走的钢丝极其险恶，甚至可能是致命的。因此，马略正踏上这条潜在致命的钢丝，赌注非常高，休息过后我们将了解接下来会发生什么。本集节目由亚马逊赞助播出。汤姆，纵观历史，
change has often been driven by businesses and institutions that end up having a massive impact on society as a whole and there's probably no better example than the Ford Motor Company. Henry Ford and his business, managers revolutionized production through their pioneering assembly lines. And they influenced factories and working practices in countries all over the world. Another example of a business driving technological and social change is Amazon, which is increasing the number of its
变革往往是由最终对整个社会产生巨大影响的企业和机构推动的，而福特汽车公司大概就是最好的例子。亨利·福特和他的企业管理者们通过开创性的装配线彻底革新了生产方式。他们影响了世界各地国家的工厂和工作实践。推动技术和社会变革的另一个例子是亚马逊，该公司正在增加其在欧洲用于配送的
electric vehicles used for deliveries in Europe to over 10,000 by the end of this year, 2026. Now, on top of that, over 50% of Amazon deliveries now come with less packaging or sometimes no added packaging at all. It helps to avoid unnecessary waste and it makes recycling at home that much easier. Find out more at amazon.co.com.uk slash sustainability. Hey, this is Michael and Hannah from Goldhangers. The Rest is Science. This episode is brought to you by Cancer Research UK. When we talk about beating cancer, we often focus a lot on. survival, and that can mean overlooking impacts that last long after treatment ends.
电动汽车数量，到今年（2026年）年底将超过10,000辆。不仅如此，如今亚马逊超过50%的配送都采用更少的包装，有时甚至完全没有添加额外的包装。这有助于避免不必要的浪费，并使家里的回收利用变得更加容易。请访问 amazon.co.uk/sustainability 了解更多信息。嘿，我是来自《归根结底是科学》（Goldhangers. The Rest is Science）的迈克尔和汉娜。本集节目由英国癌症研究中心赞助播出。当我们谈论战胜癌症时，我们经常把重点放在生存率上，
Yeah, for example, take cancers in children and young people. The treatments themselves can be incredibly harsh. They can cause lifelong side effects like infertility or hearing loss. And Cancer Research UK is working to change that because young people, they should be able to grow up hearing the voices of the people that they love and living their lives to the fullest. That's right. And one clinical trial led by Cancer Research UK showed that giving another drug alongside chemotherapy nearly halved the number of children losing their hearing. And today, the treatment combination is being used by doctors across the world. For more information about Cancer Research UK, their research and breakthroughs and how you can support them, visit
这可能意味着忽略了治疗结束后长期存在的持久影响。是的，例如，以儿童和年轻人的癌症为例。治疗本身可能极其残酷。它们会导致终身副作用，如不孕不育或听力损失。英国癌症研究中心正在努力改变这一现状，因为年轻人本应该能够长大成人，倾听他们所爱之人的声音，并充实地生活。没错。英国癌症研究中心领导的一项临床试验表明，在化疗的同时给予另一种药物，使儿童听力受损的人数几乎减少了一半。如今，世界各地的医生都在使用这种治疗组合。有关英国癌症研究中心、他们的研究和突破以及您如何支持他们的更多信息，请访问
cancerresearchukuk.org slash rest is science. Hola, Camaradas. It's Dominic here. Sorry to interrupt the episode, but I just thought you'd like to know that we've been thinking about something that you've been writing to us a lot. one of the most requested subjects ever since we started the rest of its history, which is the Spanish Civil War. Now, I can tell you exclusively that plans are afoot for us to do the Spanish Civil War at some point, hopefully next year in 2027. But as a little taster or teaser, on our sister show, The Book Club, my co-presenter Tabby and I have just released an episode on perhaps the emblematic novel of the Spanish Civil War, which is Ernest Hemingway's book for whom the bell tolls.
cancerresearchuk.org/restisscience。大家好，老朋友们（Hola, Camaradas）。我是多米尼克。很抱歉打断这一集，但我只是觉得你们会想知道，我们一直在思考你们经常写信给我们的一件事。自我们开办《历史的其余部分》以来，最受请求的主题之一就是西班牙内战。现在我可以独家告诉你们，我们正计划在某个时候开展西班牙内战的内容，希望在明年，即2027年。但作为一小道开胃菜或预告，在我们的姊妹节目《读书俱乐部》中，我的联合主持人塔比和我刚刚发布了一集节目，探讨的也许是西班牙内战中最具象征意义的小说，也就是欧内斯特·海明威的书《丧钟为谁而鸣》。
So in this episode, we do dig into the history. We talk about the clash between fascism and idealism. We talk about the roots of the conflict. And of course, the way in which it drew in so many foreign intellectuals and artists and writers, Hemingway, of course, among them. And many of you will know that Hemingway was in Spain during the war. He was a correspondent in Madrid, which was under siege by Franco's forces. And he draws on that experience.
所以在这一集中，我们深入探讨了历史。我们讨论了法西斯主义与理想主义之间的冲突。我们讨论了冲突的根源。当然，还有它吸引了如此多的外国知识分子、艺术家和作家的吸引力，海明威当然也是其中之一。你们中的许多人都会知道，海明威在战争期间身在西班牙。他是马德里的战地记者，当时马德里正被弗朗哥的军队围困。他借鉴了那段经历，
in for whom the bell tolls, to tell the story of an American volunteer who's part of a guerrilla unit who are fighting Franco's troops. So if you keep listening at the end of this episode, we will have an exclusive short clip which discusses the history of the Spanish Civil War. Welcome back, everybody, to the rest is history of the year is 119 BC. And the ambitious provincial self-made man Gaius Marius, who is now already in his late 30s. who's only two years short of his 40th birthday. He has won his first major political office, his first major magistracy. He has become, as he intended, a tribune of the plebs.
写进《丧钟为谁而鸣》中，讲述了一个美国志愿者的故事，他是与弗朗哥军队作战的游击队成员。因此，如果你在本集结束时继续收听，我们将播放一小段独家剪辑，讨论西班牙内战的历史。欢迎大家回到《历史的其余部分》，今年是公元前119年。雄心勃勃的来自外省的白手起家的盖乌斯·马略，现在已经三十多岁了。距离他四十岁生日仅差两年。他赢得了他的第一个重大政治职位，他的第一个重大官职。他正如他所愿，成为了平民保民官。
And as we were saying before the break, Tom, although it's meant supposedly inviolate, this is an increasingly dangerous role in the febriarch politics of Rome at this point for a man like Marius to hold. Now, why specifically at this point is this so politically feebrile? What makes this so contentious? Because the previous decade and a half, the tribunate had been used to foster what, in the opinion of conservatives in the Senate, are very radical, very dangerous and in the opinion of conservatives, very un-Roman reforms and policies.
正如我们在休息前所说的那样，汤姆，尽管这意味着所谓不可侵犯，但对于像马略这样的人来说，在当时罗马狂热的政治氛围中，这是一个日益危险的角色。现在，为什么具体在这个时候，政治会如此狂热？是什么让这一切如此充满争议？因为在过去的十五年里，保民官一直被用来推动在元老院保守派看来非常激进、非常危险，而在保守派看来非常非罗马的改革和政策。
And these have been pushed by two brothers. The eldest of these is Tiberius Crackers. he had become tribune in 133 BC. His younger brother, Gaius Gracchus, he had become tribune 10 years later. And both these brothers had used their tribunates to push for reforms that were very overtly in favour of the poor. So the measures that they pushed for included having publicly held land, state held land, being divided up and given as allotments to those who had no land in the city. so the bottom of the bottom, the most impoverished layers of Roman society. They had pressed for corn to be sold below the market rate, so subsidised food, and they pushed for the poorest citizens when they got levied into the army to be given
这些是由两兄弟推动的。其中年龄较大的是提比略·格拉库斯。他在公元前133年成为保民官。他的弟弟盖乌斯·格拉库斯在10年后成为保民官。这两兄弟都利用他们的保民官职位来推动那些明显有利于穷人的改革。因此，他们推动的措施包括将公有土地、国库土地分割开来，分给城里没有土地的人，即社会底层、最贫困的罗马阶层。他们力求以低于市场价的价格出售粮食，也就是补贴食品，并且他们推动最贫困的公民在被征入军队时能够获得
their own clothes, their own kind of kit and equipment. And this was seen by the Senate as monstrously left wing, to be anachronistic about it. Militant class war politics. Yeah, and particularly, Gaius Gracchus, the younger, the Tony Ben of Republican Rome, because he had far more than his elder brother, a very self-consciously revolutionary vision. So he, basically, he wanted to turn the republic into a kind of version of the democracy that the Athenians had. He wanted very deliberately to alter the balance of power between the nobleses, between the, the senatorial elite,
他们自己的衣服、他们自己的装备和器材。用历史错位的话来说，元老院认为这是极其左翼的行为。激进的阶级战争政治。是的，尤其是年轻的盖乌斯·格拉库斯，他是共和时代罗马的托尼·本，因为他比他的哥哥更有自觉的革命愿景。所以他基本上想把共和国变成雅典民主的一种版本。他非常刻意地改变贵族、元老院精英之间的权力平衡，
and the mass of the people. And I suppose ultimately, he wanted to enshrine the populace, the people as the arbiters of Rome, rather than the sonatus, the Senate. So it would be, I guess, the people in the Senate of Rome rather than the other way around. That's his kind of ambition. And to conservatives in the Senate, I mean, this is beyond the pale. This is monstrous. And they see Tiberius Gracus and particularly Gaius gracus as potential tyrants. Why else would they be pushing these reforms? It could only be because they want absolute power. And something that confirms the senatorial conservatives in this opinion is a very sinister trend. So Tiberius Grakus, when he'd finished his one year as Tribune, he'd immediately sought re-election. And Gaius
以及广大人民。我想他最终是想把民众、人民奉为罗马的仲裁者，而不是元老院。所以我想这会变成罗马的人民和元老院，而不是反过来。这就是他的某种雄心。对于元老院的保守派来说，这简直不可理喻。这是怪物般的行径。他们视提比略·格拉库斯，尤其是盖乌斯·格拉库斯为潜在的暴君。他们推动这些改革还能有什么别的动机？唯一的可能就是他们想要绝对权力。而证实元老院保守派这种观点的，是一种非常险恶的趋势。因此，提比略·格拉库斯在完成他一年的保民官任期后，立即寻求连任。而盖乌斯
in 122 BC, he'd finished his term, stood again, and actually been elected. And this is really sinister because it is pretty fundamental to the way that the Romans understand politics, that you shouldn't hold a magistracy for more than one year. Because if you do, then you have the chance to entrench your own powers, your own support. And so the enemy of the Gracki in the Senate feel themselves entirely justified in imagining that it is an ambition for tyranny that is motivating the Gracky. And that the office of the tribunate may be inviolate, but it's not as inviolate as maintaining the integrity of the Republic.
在公元前122年，他任期结束时再次参选，并且真的当选了。这真的很险恶，因为罗马人对政治的理解有一个相当根本的原则，那就是你不应该担任某个官职超过一年。因为如果你这样做，你就有机会巩固你自己的权力和支持。因此，元老院中格拉库斯兄弟的敌人们完全有理由认为，是追求暴政的野心激励着格拉库斯兄弟。而且保民官这个职位可能是不容侵犯的，但它没有维护共和国的完整性那么不容侵犯。
And so twice this great cry had gone up that the Republic needs defending, the Constitution is in peril, and twice this cry had been answered. So in 133, Tiberius Gracchus had been clubbed to death with the leg of a stool. He'd been cornered and had his head smashed to pieces. And then in one, two, one, Gaius, as we heard before the break, he'd been murdered, his corpse decapitated, the skull filled with lead, and 3,000 of his followers had been rounded up and executed without trial by the consuls. And these executions had been justified in terms of a national emergency. To stress, if people think, well, this is probably part of the run in the mill, Roman politics is very violent.
因此，两次发出了“共和国需要保卫、宪法处于危险之中”的巨大呼吁，两次都得到了响应。所以在133年，提比略·格拉库斯被用凳子腿殴打致死。他被逼入绝境，头部被砸得粉碎。然后在121年，盖乌斯正如我们在休息前听到的那样，被谋杀，尸体被斩首，头骨里灌满了铅，三千名追随者被执政官未经审判就逮捕并处决。这些处决是以国家紧急状态为由进行辩解的。需要强调的是，如果人们认为这可能是日常罗马政治的一部分，而罗马政治非常暴力，
That's not right at all right. This is a massive rupture with the previous traditions of Roman politics. Completely. These are the first eruptions of civil violence. on the streets of Rome since the expulsion of the monarchy back in 509 BC. It's that big a deal.
那可大错特错了。这与以往罗马政治的传统发生了巨大的断裂。完全如此。这是自公元前509年驱逐君主制以来，罗马街头首次爆发公民暴力事件。事情就是这么大。
Wow. So for 400 years or so? For 400 years. And it is experiencing something completely shocking. So what's the significance of these atrocities? I think both more and less than they seem. So more because it's a fatal precedent.
哇。所以大约400年没有过了？整整400年。而它正在经历一件完全令人震惊的事情。那么这些暴行的意义何在？我认为它们既比看上去更多，也比看上去更少。更多是因为这是一个致命的先例。
I guess if you're being florid, you would say that a fatal toxin. has been injected into the body politic. And we're never floored. If a consul can justify putting an elected tribune to death and completely ignoring his inviolability simply by referencing a national emergency, then what's the stop magistrates in the future doing exactly the same?
我想如果说得浮夸一点，你会说一种致命的毒素已被注入政治体中。而我们绝不浮夸。如果执政官仅仅通过引用国家紧急状态，就可以证明处决一名当选的保民官并完全无视其不可侵犯性是正当的，那么有什么能阻止未来的官吏做完全相同的事情呢？
I mean, it's a kind of FIMA process, isn't it? It leads to bad places. If you can kill a tribune, then why can't you, you can kill anybody. I mean, one consul could kill another consul and say there are a threat to the survival of the Republic. Because when you break a taboo, the taboo is never as strong as it had been before it was broken.
我的意思是，这是一个滚雪球的过程，不是吗？它通往糟糕的方向。如果你能杀死一个保民官，那你为什么不能杀任何人呢？我的意思是，一个执政官可以杀死另一个执政官，并声称他们对共和国的生存构成了威胁。因为当你打破一个禁忌时，这个禁忌就永远不会像它被打破之前那样强大了。
Exactly say. So it's very pregnant with menace for the future. At the same time, I think it's kind of less than it seems because the instincts of the Romans remain across the board, incredibly conservative. There isn't actually a threat of, open class warfare, of the kind that was always tearing Greek cities apart. And this is because, as we've said, the Romans, the mass of the Romans, are just inherently very, very conservative.
完全正确。所以它对未来充满了威胁。与此同时，我认为它比看上去要少，因为罗马人的本能总体而言仍然令人难以置信地保守。实际上并不存在公开阶级战争的威胁，不像那种总是把希腊城邦撕裂的阶级战争。这是因为，正如我们所说，罗马人，广大的罗马人，本质上就是非常非常保守的。
They may feel resentful of the elites, but they simultaneously feel very respectful of them. Again, I think there's something of the way that maybe, I mean, American listeners may disagree with this, but from this side of the Atlantic, people seem to really hate billionaires in America, but also simultaneously respect them. Yeah. And I think there's something of that in the kind of the Roman attitude to the senatorial elite.
他们可能会对精英感到不满，但他们同时又对精英感到非常尊敬。同样，我觉得这有点像那种方式，也许，虽然美国听众可能会对此有异议，但从大西洋的这一边来看，美国人似乎真的很讨厌亿万富翁，但同时也尊重他们。是的。我认为罗马人对元老院精英的态度中也有类似的东西。
It's part of the tradition that the Senate and the people should work together and the people feel that tradition to be as precious as the Senate do. So it's not like actually Rome is going to collapse into, as I say, into class conflict. And so this, for someone like Marius, you know, here is an opportunity
元老院和人民应该共同合作是传统的一部分，人民觉得这个传统和元老院一样珍贵。所以罗马并不真的会像我所说的那样陷入阶级冲突。因此，对于像马略这样的人来说，这是一个机会，
because he is perfectly suited to play the part of the people's friend. a popularis in Latin. You could translate that perhaps as a populist. People are very nervous, you know, among the tribunes, they're very nervous of pushing legislation that might offend the elites because they've seen what's happened. But Marius is bold enough to do this.
因为他非常适合扮演“人民之友”的角色。拉丁语中叫popularis。你也许可以把它翻译成“平民主义者”。人们非常紧张，你知道，在保民官中，他们非常害怕通过可能激怒精英的立法，因为他们已经看到了发生的事情。但马略有足够的胆量这样做。
So he passes a bill that restricts the ability of the Nobel-Aze to influence voters in the voting pens. It's kind of like it's not exactly introducing a secret ban it, but it's kind of something along those lines. And this is the first overtly populist gesture since the death of Gaius Gracchus. And to quote Plutarch, this won him a reputation as a person of great courage, a formidable opponent of the Conservatives in the Senate, and someone who could be relied upon to stick up for the common man.
于是他通过了一项法案，限制了贵族（nobilate）在投票栏内影响选民的能力。这有点像，虽然不完全是引入秘密投票，但有点类似于这种性质。这是自盖乌斯·格拉库斯死后第一个公开的平民主义姿态。引用普鲁塔克的话，这为他赢得了一个享有巨大勇气的名声，成为元老院保守派的可畏对手，并且是一个可以信赖来为普通人挺身而出的人。
And Plutarch isn't exaggerating there. Marius was, I think, being brave because it is a period of massive reaction. So the historian Salas, writing a few decades later, he described it as a kind of a faction of the of the few, rule by the few. Just as, and these few consist of just the, you know, the top, the grandest, the snootiest noblets. And among these noblets are the Mattelli. So obviously, for you were asking previously, you know, is there a risk for Marius of running against the interests of the Metali?
普鲁塔克并没有夸大其词。马略当时确实很勇敢，因为这是一个强烈反动的时期。因此，几十年后写作的历史学家萨卢斯特将其描述为一种少数人的集团，由少数人统治。正如，而这少数人仅由最顶尖、最显赫、最傲慢的贵族组成。而这些贵族当中就包括梅特利家族。所以很显然，就像你之前问的那样，马略与梅特利家族利益对立是否有风险？
There absolutely is because the Mattelli are furious with him for, you know, this law that he's introduced and they withdraw their patronage. And this has a knock-on effect for Marius' prospects, because for several years after his tribunate, he struggles to get another magistracy. And in fact, in 116, massive embarrassment, he manages to lose two elections on the same day. Oh, my God. You know, he's clearly not doing well. But, you know, to pursue the sports analogy, he backs himself.
绝对有，因为梅特利家族对他的这一举动怒不可遏，因为他出台了这项法律，他们撤回了赞助。这对马略的前景产生了连锁反应，因为在他担任保民官后的好几年里，他很难再获得另一个官职。事实上，在116年，他遭遇了巨大的尴尬，在同一天输掉了两场选举。天哪。你知道，他显然过得并不好。但是，你知道，用体育的比喻来说，他对自己很有信心。
Right. He's not going to be cast down by a few disappointments. Form is temporary, class is permanent. and he's got class. He's got class, and the evidence of that class is that he's able to keep the backing of the people, but in due course he's able to win back the support of the Mattelli, because the Mattelli can see he is actually someone it's worth having on side. And so relations between them are patched up.
对吧。他不会被几次挫折所击倒。状态是暂时的，阶级是永恒的，而他有阶级。他有阶级，而这个阶级的证据就是他能够保持人民的支持，但在适当的时候，他能够重新赢得梅特利家族的支持，因为梅特利家族可以看到他实际上是一个值得拉拢的人。于是他们之间的关系得到了修复。
And so a decade on from his tribunate, Maris is back in the race. You know, the cursus sonorum is going well for him. He's secured admittedly by the skin of his life. teeth, but, you know, he's got it, a governorship in Spain. And this enables him to do what he does best, which is to demonstrate his talents as a commander. And he promotes himself as a kind of no-nonsense enthusiast for law and order. Common-sense governorship. So again, to quote Plutarch, the province back then that Spain was still very savage and uncivilised since the Spaniards thought banditory an honourable profession. And Marius is having none of that. Lots of crucifixions and scuris.
因此，在他担任保民官十年后，马略重返赛场。你知道，他的晋升阶梯对他来说进展顺利。他确实赢得了职位，尽管可以说是死里逃生，但不管怎样，他得到了，在西班牙担任总督。这使他能够做他最擅长的事情，那就是展示他作为指挥官的才能。他将自己标榜为一个对法律和秩序毫不妥协的热心支持者。常识性治理。所以再次引用普鲁塔克的话，当时的西班牙那个省份仍然非常野蛮和未开化，因为西班牙人认为拦路抢劫是一种光荣的职业。而马略绝不容忍这一点。大量的钉十字架和严厉惩罚，
and enslavements. As I say, common sense. So he's robust. He's robust in Spain. But also he, now we haven't mentioned his personal life at all, but actually his personal life has taken a very exciting term because he is married into, well, the most single, most well-known family in all Roman history, hasn't he? He has. Yes. Although at the time, it's very ancient, it's very patrician, but it's slightly down on its luck. It hasn't had a great success in elections for centuries and more. And this, of course, is the family of the Caesars. So Marius marries Julia, who is the sister of the father of Julius Caesar.
以及奴役。就像我说的，常识。所以他在西班牙雷厉风行。但同时，我们还没有提到他的私生活，但实际上他的私生活发生了非常激动人心的转折，因为他娶了，嗯，罗马历史上最著名家族的成员，不是吗？是的，他娶了。尽管当时这个家族非常古老，非常显赫，但有点时运不济。几个世纪以来，它在选举中并没有取得巨大的成功。而这当然就是恺撒家族。所以马略娶了朱莉娅，她是尤利乌斯·恺撒父亲的妹妹。
So Marius is going to be the young Julius Caesar's marital uncle. And so big part in Colley McCulloch's books, all of this. Yeah. So Maris is being knitted into the, you know, a key aristocratic family. And he's got the Mattelli back on side by this point. Yeah. So brilliant. And this is crucial because he's got the backing of one Mattelis in particular.
所以马略将是年轻的尤利乌斯·恺撒的姑父。所有这些都是科林·麦卡洛（Collie McCulloch）书中很大的一部分。是的。所以马略被编织进了，你知道的，一个关键的贵族家庭。而且此时他已经让梅特利家族重新回到了他这一边。是的。所以太棒了。这至关重要，因为他得到了某位特定梅特利家族成员的支持。
And this is a guy called Quintus Caichelius Mattelis, who is he is an absolutely instinctive oligarch. I mean, he's very much politically not Maris's cup of tea. He's a person of great personal integrity, but in that kind of flinty, slightly off. putting manner that is characteristic of very moral upstanding Romans. But crucially for Marius, this reputation as someone who is both very upstanding and a very effective soldier has won Mattelis election ship to the consulship for the year 109. And this is great for Marius because Mattelis as consul has been appointed to the command of an exceedingly challenging war in Africa, and this in turn means that Mattelis is going to need
这是一个名叫昆图斯·凯基利乌斯·梅特利乌斯（Quintus Caecilius Metellus）的人，他绝对是一个本能的寡头。我的意思是，在政治上，他很不合马略的胃口。他是一个极具个人正直的人，但带有一种顽固的、略带拒人于千里之外的举止，这是道德高尚的罗马人的典型特征。但对马略至关重要的是，这种既正直又高效的军人声誉，让梅特利乌斯赢得了公元前109年的执政官职位。这对马略来说太棒了，因为梅特利乌斯作为执政官，被任命指挥非洲一场极具挑战性的战争，这反过来意味着梅特利乌斯将需要
a trusted and competent Legatus, a number two, a deputy. And Marius is the obvious candidate. He's a man of proven courage, of proven ability, and he is also a long-term client of the Mattelie. And so Marius says yes, isn't he? And he says yes, both because he's obviously, he's obviously very good at fighting wars, so be mad for him to say no. But also, you know, the military sphere and the political sphere are, you know, they're interconnected, aren't they in Rome in this period? And Marius is thinking that, you know, proving himself on the battlefield is the perfect way to reboot his stalled political career. Well, I think more specifically, it might give him a chance to have a crack at the ultimate and go for the consulship. And Marius hasn't told Mattelus this.
一个受信任且能干的副将（legatus），一个二把手，一个副手。而马略是不二之选。他是一个被证明具有勇气、被证明有能力的人，而且他也是梅特利家族的长期附庸。于是马略答应了，不是吗？他答应了，不仅因为他显然很擅长打仗，如果他说不那就太疯狂了。而且，你知道，在这一时期的罗马，军事领域和政治领域是相互交织的，不是吗？马略认为，在战场上证明自己是重启他停滞不前的政治生涯的绝佳方式。嗯，我认为更具体地说，这可能给他一个机会去尝试终极目标，去竞选执政官。而马略并没有把这一点告诉梅特利乌斯。
It's like a kind of dream that he's hugging. to himself. But his plan, I think, is to go to Africa, to win a few dashing victories, to make a name for himself in Rome, to have his backers in Rome, of which he has quite a lot by this point, to kind of really hype him up.
这就像是一个他藏在心里的梦想。但我认为他的计划是去非洲，赢得一些轰动的胜利，在罗马扬名立万，让他在罗马的支持者——此时他已经有很多支持者了——真正为他大肆宣传，
And then to go back, run for election, and, you know, he might be in with a chance. But obviously, this does require him to make a good fist of things in Africa. And things there have not been going well for the Romans at all. So it's not going to be easy. So reason for this is because they are up against an enemy who knows them very, very well. And this is none other than an old
然后回去参选，并且，你知道，他可能会有机会。但显而易见，这确实要求他在非洲干出一番名堂。而那里的情况对罗马人来说一直很不妙。所以这不会容易。原因在于他们面对的是一个非常非常了解他们的敌人。而这正是马略的老战友之一。他们曾一同在努曼蒂亚服役。这就是努米底亚王子朱古达（Jugurtha），那个曾带骑兵和12头大象去努曼蒂亚的人。我说他是王子，但实际上到了这个时候，他已经杀了他两个堂兄，也就是努米底亚王位的合法继承人、合法的王子，自己当上了努米底亚国王。所以他是个坐在王位上的篡位者。为了打通他权力上升的道路，为了获得罗马当权者的批准，他进行了大量的贿赂。他到处撒钱。
comrade of arms of Marius. They'd served together at Numantia. And this is the Numidian prince, Jugurtha, the guy who had brought the cavalry and the 12 elephants to Neumantia. And I say prince, but in fact by this point, he's killed his two cousins who are the legitimate heirs to the Numidian throne, the legitimate princes, and made himself the king of Numidia. So he's a usurper sitting on the throne. And to oil the wheels of his rise to power to get the approval of the powers that be in Rome, he has lavished massive bribes. He's just been spraying them around.
甚至连朱古达都对这揭示出的罗马城中的腐败程度感到惊讶，而这座城市本应由坚定的、顽强的、不妥协的道德家组成。对吧。他留下了一个非常著名的关于罗马的评论，由萨卢斯特记录了下来，他将这座城市描述为“一座待售的城市，一旦找到买家就会面临灭顶之灾”。最重要的是，朱古达把事情推得太远的另一个原因是，他一直没有表现得像罗马人所认为的那种驯服的附属国国王那样。所以在公元前112年，在公然违背罗马指示的情况下，他进攻并
And even Jigurtha had been surprised by the level of corruption that this had revealed in a city supposedly made up of stern, flinty, unyielding moralists. Right. And he made a very famous. comment on Rome, which Salas recorded, he described it as a city for sale and bound for imminent destruction, should a buyer be found. And on top of this, the other reason that Jagurtha has really been pushing things too far is that he hasn't been behaving as the Romans think a kind of tame client king should. So in 112, in direct contravention of Roman instructions, he had attacked and
杀死了他的两个堂兄中的第二个，后者曾撤退并龟缩在一个叫基尔塔（Cirta）的小镇里。在这场罗马本来就告诉过朱古达不要进行的进攻中，朱古达的人杀害了许多罗马人。不管朱古达向他们塞了多少贿赂，这对于罗马元老院来说实在是太过分了。所以他们想，好吧，这太过分了。我们需要推翻他。然而，事实证明这说起来容易做起来难。原因有很多。首先，努米底亚地势平坦开阔，是完美的骑兵作战地带。而罗马人的优势当然是他们的军团，他们的重步兵。此外，罗马在非洲的军队非常松懈、状态糟糕。所以他们需要一个严格的
killed the second of his two cousins who'd kind of retreated and he's holed up in a town called Kirta. And in the course of this attack, which the Romans had told Jagurtha anyway not to do, Jagurtha's men had killed a number of Romans. And this is too much, really, for the Senate back in Rome, no matter how many bribes Jagertha is shoveling their way. And so they think, okay, this has gone too far. We need to topple him. This, however, proves easier said than done. reasons for this are numerous. Firstly, Numidia is kind of flat and open, so it's perfect cavalry country. And the strength of the Romans, of course, is their legions, their heavy infantry. Also, the Roman forces in Africa are very flabby and out of shape. So they need a strict
纪律严明的人出现并把他们操练成型。而派去与朱古达作战的执政官表现得极其无能。而且，你知道，这导致了一系列令人尴尬的失败。所以再次用体育的比喻来说。你知道，英格兰主帅输给了安道尔。是的，或者冰岛。或者冰岛，是的。而梅特利乌斯就是被指派去把他们操练成型的人。是的，基本上，他们一直在跟太太团鬼混。
disciplinarian to turn up and whip them into shape. And a consul who had been sent out to fight Jagertha had shown himself to be absolutely useless. And, you know, it resulted in a series of embarrassing defeats. So again, to pursue the sporting analogy. You know, The England manager has lost to Andorra. Yeah, to Iceland. Or Iceland, yes. And Mattelis is the guy who's been appointed to go and whip them into shape. Yeah, basically, they've been messing around with wags.
没错。他们几乎不训练。你来了一个新教练，是个纪律严明的人。他带来了马略作为二把手。是的，他是个定位球教练什么的。对吧。没错，这个面色严厉的定位球教练会让他们训练，
Yeah, exactly. They're barely training. And you've got a new manager who's a discipline there. And he's bringing in Marius, who is the number two. Yeah, who's the set piece coach or whatever. Yeah, exactly. Grim-faced set-piece coach who will make them, like, train. six times a day. Yes. So Salas describes Mattelis as a formidable and unrelenting man,
一天六次。是的。所以萨卢斯特将梅特利乌斯描述为一个可怕而严厉的人，
and so he is. He goes in, gets them onto the training crowd, you know, practicing their corners, whatever, and whips them into shape. And then he gets them ready. They go on the offensive. They defeat Jagertha in a pitched battle. All Jagurtha's war elephants are wiped out, and Mattelis very cleverly then starts suborning Jagirtha's inner circle so that Jagirtha doesn't know who he can, who he can trust. Djirthirthorfer inevitably opts for a guerrilla war. this is the classic thing. I mean, you know, this is with Numidia is the place where the French will end up fighting their war in Algeria, centuries and centuries later.
他的确如此。他介入进去，让他们来到训练场，你知道，练习他们的角球之类的，把他们操练成型。然后他让他们做好准备。他们发动进攻。他们在阵地战中击败了朱古达。朱古达的所有战象都被消灭了，随后梅特利乌斯非常聪明地开始收买朱古达的内圈核心，让朱古达不知道自己究竟能信任谁。朱古达不可避免地选择了游击战。这是经典之战。我的意思是，你知道，努米底亚就是几个世纪后法国人最终在阿尔及利亚进行战争的地方。
And Mattelis, rather like the French do, he responds by ravaging the countryside, taking vast numbers of prisoners, capturing settlements one by one, burning them if they resist, kind of calculated series of atrocities. And the Senate think this is brilliant, to quote Salas. They decreed supplications to the immortal gods in return for the successful deeds of Mattelis. And really the only fly in the ointment, as Mattelis is year, as consul draws to a close, is the fact that Jagertha is still on the loose. But Mattelis is assuming that that's not really an issue, he's done so well that even though he's no longer consul,
而梅特利乌斯就像法国人一样，通过蹂躏乡村、俘虏大量囚犯、逐一攻克定居点、如果他们反抗就将其烧毁来进行回应，这是一系列精心策划的暴行。元老院认为这太棒了，引用萨卢斯特的话：“他们为了梅特利乌斯的成功业绩，向不朽神明下令举行感恩祈祷。”当梅特利乌斯作为执政官的任期接近尾声时，唯一的瑕疵就是朱古达仍然在逃。但梅特利乌斯假设这并不是什么真正的问题，他做得太好了，以至于即使他不再担任执政官，
he's presuming that he will continue to be in charge of this war. And it is at this point that Marius makes his move. So in the summer of 108, he goes to Metellus. And he says that he wants to head back to Rome and he wants to run for the consulship. And Mattelis is stunned by this. You know, he responds with complete astonishment, then with contempt, and then he makes a joke of it. But Marius is absolutely obdurate. And Mattelis, who thinks he hasn't got a hope.
他推测自己仍将继续掌管这场战争。正是在这个时候，马略采取了行动。因此在公元前108年夏天，他去找梅特利乌斯。他说他想回罗马去竞选执政官。梅特利乌斯对此惊呆了。你知道，他的反应先是完全的震惊，然后是不屑，接着拿这事开玩笑。但马略态度极其坚决。而梅特利乌斯认为他毫无希望。
I mean, he's just a novice homo. What hope does he possibly have? He says, fine, okay, you can go back. But very pointedly, he keeps Marius with him in the field until the very last moment, so that Marius only gets back to Rome in the very nick of time to register himself for the consular election. And I think that Mattelis is doing this to ensure that Marius won't have time to do any of the campaigning that is essentially if you're going to be consul. But Mattelis has badly underestimated Marius because we said that Marius has lots of agents back in Rome.
我的意思是，他只是个新贵。他到底能有什么希望？他说，好吧，你可以回去。但非常刻意的是，他把马略留在前线直到最后一刻，以至于马略在千钧一发之际才回到罗马去登记参加执政官选举。我想梅特利乌斯这样做是为了确保马略没有时间进行竞选活动，而这对于你想当执政官来说是至关重要的。但梅特利乌斯严重低估了马略，因为我们说过马略在罗马有很多代理人。
And unknown to Mattelis, these have been doing a lot of campaigning while Maris has been away in Africa. And they have been playing the popularis card. They've been saying, look, Mattelis is stiff, arrogant, chilly, haughty. This isn't the kind of person that we want. What we want is a man of the people, a man like you. That's pretty sneaky of Matt. Marius is turning on his own patron. He completely is.
而梅特利乌斯不知道的是，当马略在非洲时，这些人一直在进行大量的竞选活动。他们一直在打平民主义牌。他们一直在说，看，梅特利乌斯死板、傲慢、冷淡、高傲。这不是我们想要的人。我们想要的是一个平民，像你这样的人。马略背叛了自己的赞助人，这真是太阴险了。他完全背叛了。
That's poor. That has slightly messed with my sense of Gaius Maris, who I always thought was... It's like Rupert Lowe turning on Nigel Farage. That is absolutely not the analogy that I would have picked. So I always thought that Marius would never have stooped to that, but I was wrong. Well, we said he gives the impression of being, I think, a bit of a meathead. Yeah. But that's the show.
这太糟糕了。这有点打破了我对盖乌斯·马略的印象，我一直以为他……这就像鲁珀特·洛（Rupert Lowe）背叛奈杰尔·法拉奇（Nigel Farage）一样。这绝对不是我会选的比喻。所以我一直认为马略绝不会做出那种事，但我错了。嗯，我们说过他给人留下的印象是，我觉得他有点像个头脑简单的人。是的。但节目就是这样。
Marius is a very shrewd calculating commander, but also a politician. He's very, very effective. And he knows that, you know, in politics as in war, you have to prepare for success. And that's what he's been doing. And he knows that there is a huge constituency, and not just among the mass of the people in the Senate as well, who are fed up with this kind of faction of the few, these guys who've been in control and hogging the consulship for year after year after year and want them out of the way. And so he is the guy who dares to put his head above the parapet, and he duly reaps the reward. So not only is he elected consul for 107 BC, he gets Mattelis's African command. My God, if you're Metellus, you are absolutely raging at this point.
马略是一个非常精明、会算计的指挥官，同时也是一个政治家。他非常非常高效。他知道，在政治中和在战争中一样，你必须为成功做好准备。这就是他一直在做的事情。他知道有一个庞大的选民群体，不仅在广大人民中，在元老院里也是如此，他们对这种少数人的集团、这些年复一年垄断执政官职位的家伙们已经厌烦了，想把他们赶走。所以他是那个敢于把头伸出掩体的人，他也理所应当地收获了回报。因此，他不仅当选为公元前107年的执政官，他还得到了梅特利乌斯的非洲指挥权。天哪，如果你是梅特利乌斯，你此时此刻一定气炸了。
Oh, he's furious. He's absolutely livid. He's the guy who's basically defeated Gertha, and he's closing in on the kill. And just as he's doing that, suddenly he gets a message saying you've got to hand over your command to your former deputy. But it is what it is. You know, Mattelis has got to do what the Senate tells him. And so he goes back to Rome in a massive strok. And his mates in the Senate there try to make things up for him by voting him a splendid title, Numidicus.
哦，他怒火中烧。他绝对出离愤怒了。他本来是那个基本上击败了朱古达、正步步逼近将其消灭的人。正当他这么做的时候，突然接到一个消息，说你必须把你的指挥权移交给你的前任副手。但事已至此，木已成舟。你知道，梅特利乌斯不得不听从元老院的命令。于是他气冲冲地回到了罗马。他在元老院的死党们试图通过授予他一个显赫的称号“努米迪库斯”（Numidicus）来弥补他的损失。
you know, the guy who's defeated the Numidians. And we've said how the number of names that you have in Rome is a marker of your status. He now has a fourth name. So that's some consolation, I guess. Meanwhile, Marius is in Africa. He takes control of the war against Jagertha. And within a year, he has brought it to a successful conclusion. Jagirtha himself is driven out of Numidia and goes to Mauritania, the neighboring kingdom, what's now Morocco.
你知道的，就是那个击败了努米底亚人的家伙。我们之前说过，在罗马，你名字的数量是地位的象征。他现在有了第四个名字。所以我想这多少算是一种安慰。与此同时，马略在非洲。他接管了针对朱古达的战争。不到一年的时间，他就取得了胜利。朱古达本人被驱逐出努米底亚，逃到了邻国的毛里塔尼亚，也就是现在的摩洛哥。
but Marius is not going to leave him there to continue to stare up trouble. He wants a line drawn under the whole war with Jagertha. And so accordingly, he has an eye for talent. He's got this general staff and he picks out the shrewdest, the cleverest, the most diplomatically able, the bravest of all his lieutenants, sends this officer to the king of Mauritania to negotiate the surrender of Jagertha. and this officer, you know, proves himself to be everything that Marius had hoped, incredibly subtle, incredibly fearless. He pulls the diplomatic mission off. Jigurtha falls into Roman hands.
但马略并不打算让他在那里继续兴风作浪。他想给这场针对朱古达的战争画上句号。因此，他很有慧眼。他组建了参谋部，并挑出了他所有副手中最精明、最聪明、最善于外交、最勇敢的一个，派这名军官去毛里塔尼亚国王那里谈判，让其交出朱古达。而这个军官，如马略所期望的那样，证明了自己堪称完美，极其敏锐，无所畏惧。他成功完成了这次外交任务。朱古达落入了罗马人手中。
This lieutenant takes Jigurtha back to Marius, and Marius then heads back to Rome with Jigurtha in chains. Do you know, I've been massively looking forward to this. Well, actually, dreading it, because I remember having to translate this, like some passage about Jigurtha's in chains. Yeah, in Salist. As it was Salas, yeah, we had to do this at school. I mean, I don't want to make this switch off, but the act of translating this was soul destroying. It was so dull.
这位副将把朱古达带回给马略，随后马略带着戴着锁链的朱古达返回罗马。你知道的，我一直非常期待这一刻。其实，也心怀恐惧，因为我记得以前翻译过这个，比如一段关于朱古达戴着锁链的文字。是的，在萨卢斯特的著作里。确实是萨卢斯特，我们在学校时就得做这个。我的意思是，我不想让大家关掉节目，但这翻译过程简直太折磨人了。太枯燥了。
But you're going to make it exciting, aren't you? I thought from your enthusiasm for Colin McCulloch that you were going to say that you remember this moment as a particularly grim and terrifying moment. So Maris has gone back, and it's the 1st of January 104. So it's the New Year, the Roman New Year. And he's been given a triumph. It's a great kind of celebrated procession through the streets of Rome that gets. it's given to victorious generals, and he's celebrating it on Newer's Day.
但你会把它讲得很精彩，对吧？从你对科林·麦卡洛的热情来看，我还以为你会说你把这一刻记为一个特别阴森恐怖的时刻。所以马略回去了，当时是公元前104年1月1日。也就是新年，罗马的新年。他被授予了一场凯旋式。这是在罗马街头举行的一场盛大庆祝游行，专门献给胜利的将军，他在元旦这天庆祝凯旋。
His triumph involves him riding in a chariot, dressed in the robes of a triumphful general through Rome, with his legions, all the loot that he's taken in Numidia, and his legions following him. And Jagirtha is led in chains before the cheering mass of the Roman people, being booed and spat at, and people are throwing eggs and whatever at him. I mean, kind of moderately interesting and fun, I think. No, it's a genuinely interesting.
他的凯旋仪式包括乘坐战车，身穿凯旋将军的长袍穿过罗马，他的军团、在努米底亚掠夺的所有战利品以及他的军团都紧随其后。朱古达戴着锁链被带到欢呼的罗马大众面前，遭到嘘声和唾弃，人们向他扔鸡蛋之类的东西。我的意思是，我觉得这还算蛮有趣、蛮好玩的。不，这绝对是一个非常有趣的话题。
I think the key thing looking at your notes is that they probably didn't know the word for earlobes and that that was what threw me. Because at the end of the triumph, Gigertha is taken to one side and taken to this hideous prison. And there his earrings are pulled off and they yanked off so brutally that his entire earlobe comes away with the earrings. And surely any young Sambrook would have enjoyed that if he'd got to translate it. And then he's thrown into this freezing cold dungeon. And I'll quote Plutarch.
我觉得看你的笔记，关键在于他们可能不知道耳垂这个词是什么，正是这个难倒了我。因为在凯旋式结束时，朱古达被带到一边，押进了一个可怕的监狱。在那里，他的耳环被扯了下来，手法极其残暴，连带着他的整个耳垂都被耳环生生扯了下来。任何年轻的桑布鲁克如果当年需要翻译这一段，肯定都会乐在其中。然后他被扔进这个冰冷的地牢里。我引用一下普鲁塔克的记录。
Degyartha's wits unsettled by this and grinning horribly. He cried out by Hercules, what cold baths you have here in Rome. Great banter. I don't think it's banter. I think he's gone mad by this point already. Really? And so he's chained up down in the bottom of this hideous cell. And six days later, he dies of.
朱古达被这折磨得神志不清，咧嘴发出恐怖的狞笑。他大喊：“赫拉克勒斯啊，你们罗马的洗澡水可真够冷的！”真是妙语连珠。我不觉得这是在开玩笑。我觉得他这时候已经疯了。真的吗？于是他被锁在这个可怕地牢的最底层。六天后，他死于
the cold and malnutrition and that's the end of chigurtha and so for marius everything's turned out brilliantly so he's got his consulship he's gone to africa he's won his war he's got a brilliant name for himself as rome's greatest general there are just two slight clouds on the horizon and the first of these is that beyond the alps the teutons and the kimbri are reported to be moving on Italy. The asteroid is heading towards Earth. The zombie apocalypse is breaking out. Do you know what they are? They're the white walkers. They're the white walkers from West Ross. Yeah. And so in Rome, all eyes are fixed on Marius. He is the hero of the hour. He is Rome's greatest soldier. And so it's not surprising that it's on his shoulders that responsibility for saving the city is laid by
寒冷和营养不良，朱古达的故事就此结束。对于马略来说，一切都进展得太顺利了。他当上了执政官，去了非洲，赢得了战争，作为罗马最伟大的将军，他声名鹊起。只是地平线上出现了两朵小小的乌云。第一朵是阿尔卑斯山脉之外，条顿人和辛布里人正据报向意大利移动。一颗小行星正朝地球撞来。僵尸末日爆发了。你知道他们是谁吗？他们是异鬼。他们是来自维斯特洛的异鬼。是的。因此在罗马，所有的目光都聚焦在马略身上。他是当之无愧的英雄。他是罗马最伟大的士兵。所以，拯救城市的责任落在他肩上，也就不足为奇了，
a desperate and terrified people. Then there is a second cloud. And this is less obvious. It's more private. I'd say that at this stage, it's just a kind of a little niggle. But it is one that threatens a good deal of trouble in the future, to put it mildly. So just as Mattelus had been upstaged by Marius, so does Marius feel just a little bit upstaged by his own lieutenant. And this is, of course, the guy who had successfully negotiated the surrogated. render of Jagirtha. And this lieutenant like Marius himself is a naturally ambitious man, a man with a hyper keen sense of his own worth, and a man with all kinds of military and political talents. And there are a sum in Rome, Marius's enemies in the Senate, prominent among them, who have begun to attribute the defeat of Jagertha, not to Marius but to this lieutenant. They're saying, Marius is just showboating, the guy who really ended the war, is this person. And this person, this lieutenant, you know, he doesn't disavow this perspective.
面对的是绝望而惊恐的人民。接着是第二朵乌云。这没那么明显。它更私人一些。我想说的是，现阶段它只是一个小小的隐患。但温和地说，这是一个未来可能会引发巨大麻烦的隐患。正如梅特鲁斯曾被马略抢尽风头一样，马略现在也觉得自己的风头被手下的副将给抢了一点。而这个人，当然就是那个成功谈判促使朱古达投降的人。这位副将和马略一样，是个天生雄心勃勃的人，对自己的价值有着极高的自我认知，并且拥有各种军事和政治才能。罗马有些人，特别是马略在元老院的政敌，已经开始将击败朱古达的功劳归功于这位副将，而不是马略。他们说，马略只是在哗众取宠，真正结束战争的人其实是这家伙。而这个人，这位副将，你知道的，他并没有否认这种看法。
And in fact, he's had a signet ring made for himself, which shows him negotiating the surrender of Jagertha. And so he kind of flashes it around. And to quote Plutarch, by insisting on wearing this ring all the time, he greatly irritated Marius, who was incredibly sensitive when it came to his own honor, scorn to share his glory with. anyone else and was always ready to take a fence and Dominic the name of this lieutenant we are going to be hearing a lot about him in the episodes to come it is Lucius Cornelius soler in our next episode we are going to be finding out who he is what's his background his upbringing all of that and we will also of course be following Marius to war with the
事实上，他还让人为自己定制了一枚图章戒指，上面刻着他谈判朱古达投降的场景。于是他常常拿出来显摆。引用普鲁塔克的说法，由于坚持一直戴着这枚戒指，他极大地激怒了马略，马略对自己的荣誉极其敏感，不屑与任何人分享荣耀，总是随时准备被激怒并……这位副将的名字，我们以后还会在节目中经常听到，他就是卢修斯·科尔内利乌斯·苏拉。在下一期节目中，我们将了解他是谁、他的背景、他的成长经历以及所有这些，当然，我们也会跟随马略去迎战
teutons and the Kimbray Grigy, so exciting. So if you'd like to hear that episode right now, and if you'd like to hear the final two episodes of this absolutely thrilling swashbuckling Roman series. And if you're not already a member of the Restis History Club, because of course if you're in the club, you can listen to the next episode. Well, if you want to hear it, join our own band of Marauding Barbarian Cannibals, the Restis History Club, at the Restis History.com. And you can, of course, always find out more about this series and about this series
条顿人和辛布里人，真是太令人兴奋了。所以，如果你想现在就收听那一期节目，如果你想听这套绝对惊险刺激、充满海盗风情的罗马系列的最后两期节目。如果你还不是“历史其余部分”俱乐部的会员——因为当然，如果你是会员，你就可以收听下一期节目。好吧，如果你想听，那就加入我们自己的“游牧野蛮人食人族”帮派——“历史其余部分”俱乐部吧，网址是therestishistory.com。当然，你也可以随时通过订阅我们的时事通讯，了解更多关于这个系列以及
and about what's coming next on The Rest is History by subscribing to a newsletter. Now, if you don't want to join the Restis History Club, first of all, you're insane. So I have no time for you. I don't care what you do, frankly, because you've made poor life choices. However, you can actually, because we're kind,
接下来“历史其余部分”节目的内容。现在，如果你不想加入“历史其余部分”俱乐部，首先，你一定是疯了。所以我没时间理你。坦白说，我才不管你做什么呢，因为你作出了糟糕的人生选择。不过，由于我们很善良，其实你还可以——
you can actually hear the first five minutes of the next episode right now. We are going to be playing the first five minutes of that episode now. So after that, you probably want. will want to join the club. Now, we're only doing it because we like you. We're not doing it to entice you to join the club. Anyway, here are the next five minutes.
你现在就可以听到下一期节目前五分钟的内容。我们现在就要播放那一期节目的前五分钟。所以在听完之后，你可能就会想要加入俱乐部了。我们这么做纯粹是因为我们喜欢你们。我们可不是为了引诱你们加入俱乐部才这么做的。不管怎样，下面是接下来的五分钟内容。
Goodbye, everybody. Enjoy them. Are they? Aquevali. Even as Marius is riding through the streets of Rome and being cheered by the watching crowds, there is a mood of panic, maybe even desperation in the city,
大家再见。好好享受吧。是吗？太棒了。就在马略骑着马穿过罗马街道、接受围观群众欢呼的同时，城中弥漫着一种恐慌甚至绝望的情绪，
because Jagurtha may have been defeated. The dignity of the Roman name may have. may have been upheld in Africa, but to the north, beyond the Alps, there is a much more terrifying threat than some African king massing on the frontiers of Rome's empire. And again, we mentioned this in the previous episode. It's an immense migration of Germans, the Teutons and the Kimbray from Jutland to the frontiers of the Roman world. So it's almost a kind of proto-viking invasion. Yeah. So in the last episode, to please people who online like to count how often we refer to either the Lord of the Rings or
因为朱古达可能已经被击败了。罗马名字的尊严可能已经在非洲得到了维护，但在北方，在阿尔卑斯山脉之外，存在着比任何在罗马帝国边境集结的非洲国王更可怕的威胁。再次重申，我们在上一期节目中也提到过这一点。这是一场庞大的日耳曼人迁徙，条顿人和辛布里人从日德兰半岛迁徙到罗马世界的边境。所以这几乎是一种原始维京人的入侵。是的。所以在上一期节目中，为了讨好那些在网上喜欢统计我们提及《指环王》或
Game of Thrones, I compared them with the White Walkers, the people who in the Game of Thrones TV series you see right at the beginning, they're massing all the time. You know, all the internal politics of West Ross is nothing compared with the existential apocalyptic threat that these blokes represent. And actually, I'm going to congratulate myself on my my own comparison. I think it's an absolutely superb comparison. Yeah. Because, I mean, these people, the Teutons and the Kimbray, they're massive, they're terrifying, they look weird, they are an existential threat. They're reputed to be cannibals. Right. This is Plutarch on them. He said they were impervious to cold because they've been brought up in icebound countries full of forests.
《权力的游戏》频率的听众，我把他们比作异鬼，也就是你在《权力的游戏》电视剧一开始就看到的那些不断集结的人。你知道的，维斯特洛所有的内部政治，跟这些家伙所代表的存在主义末日威胁相比，根本不值一提。事实上，我要为自己的这个类比自我表扬一番。我觉得这是一个绝对绝妙的类比。是的。因为，我的意思是，这些人，条顿人和辛布里人，他们体型庞大，极其恐怖，长相诡异，构成了生存威胁。据传他们是食人族。没错。这就是普鲁塔克对他们的描述。他说他们对严寒免疫，因为他们是在充满森林的冰冻国度中长大的。
I mean, Tom, the parallels are stacking up. You're absolutely right. And also, isn't this also the case with the White Walkers, the Tutans and the Kimbrey accompanied by women and children. Yeah, because some of them are women and children, yeah. And in fact, actually, in Game of Thrones, the children are the most frightening. There's always something terrifying about a murderous, sinister child. And frankly, if you've ever met a German child, you know, it's the same story. Well, they're Danes, really, aren't they? Yeah, they're the worst.
汤姆，你看，相似之处越来越多了。你完全说得对。而且，这不也正是异鬼的情况吗，条顿人和辛布里人身边也带着妇女和儿童。是的，因为其中一些确实是妇女和儿童。事实上，在《权力的游戏》中，孩子们才是最可怕的。那种残暴、阴险的孩子总是透着某种恐怖。坦白说，如果你见过任何一个日耳曼小孩，你就会知道，情况完全一样。好吧，他们其实是丹麦人，对吧？是的，他们是最糟糕的。
And the women also are very frightening because they're said to fight alongside the men. Of course. And it's an entire people on the move. So there are tens of thousands of them, according to the Roman sources. I mean, we don't know how accurate they are. But basically, there are loads and loads of them. And they are experienced by the Romans less as an army than as some kind of force of nature, you know, a great flood, a tide, a tsunami, whatever you want to reach for. You know, the news had been brought to them that this monstrous tide of people is advancing towards you. And so they sent an army under a consul into a region called Norikam, which is basically Austria today in 113 BC. And the consul had set an ambush for these barbarians, and the barbarians had rumbled it and had outsmarted the consul and given him a serious mauling. And so he'd withdrawn. And he had assumed that the barbarians would pursue him and invade Italy.
而且女人们也非常可怕，因为据说她们和男人们并肩作战。当然。这是一个全族在迁徙的民族。因此，根据罗马史料记载，他们有数万人之多。我的意思是，我们不知道这些数字有多准确。但基本上，他们的人数极多。罗马人对他们的感受与其说是一支军队，不如说是一种自然力量，你知道的，一场大洪水、一阵潮汐、海啸，随便你怎么形容。你知道，消息传到了他们耳中，说这股可怕的人潮正朝着你们推进。因此，在公元前113年，他们派遣了一支由执政官率领的军队前往一个名为诺里库姆的地区，这基本上就是今天的奥地利。这位执政官为这些野蛮人设下了伏击，但野蛮人识破了诡计，智胜了执政官，并将他狠狠羞辱了一番。于是他撤退了。他本以为野蛮人会追击他并入侵意大利。
In fact, they don't. They swing westwards into Gaul, which is a big relief to the Romans. But I think it's also a little bit unsettling because it's clear that the Kimberian and the Teutans are unlike any enemy that they've come up against before. There's no predicting what they'll do. When you're fighting Carthaginians or Greeks or even Gauls, there's a sense in which the Romans understand what makes these people tick. But with these barbarians from the far north, and again, this is maybe the kind of White Walker comparison, the Romans don't understand what they want. They don't understand what's going to motivate them. They don't understand how they're going to
事实上，他们并没有。他们向西拐入高卢，这让罗马人松了一大口气。但我认为这也有些令人不安，因为很显然，辛布里人和条顿人与他们以前交过手的任何敌人都不一样。你根本无法预测他们会做什么。当你与迦太基人、希腊人甚至高卢人作战时，罗马人在某种程度上理解这些人的动机。但对于这些来自远北的野蛮人——再次说明，这或许就像异鬼的类比一样——罗马人根本不明白他们想要什么。他们不理解是什么在驱使这些人。他们不理解这些人会如何
behave. And so that means it's very difficult, I think, for the Romans to devise a strategy to cope with this onslaught. And this becomes manifest in a succession of disastrous Roman attempts to go and be proactive and meet the Teutons and Kimbury and wipe them out beyond the limits of Roman power. Because the barbarians, they're just roaming around Gaul, kind of looting and pillaging and killing and all that kind of stuff. And the Romans keep going and trying to to attack them and they keep being defeated. So first in 109 BC and then two years later near what today is Bordeaux. And one consul in that battle is killed and the other one is cornered and the only way that he can extract himself is to agree that he and his army will go beneath
行事。这就意味着，罗马人很难制定出应对这场狂潮的战略。这一点在罗马人一连串灾难性的尝试中表现得淋漓尽致，他们试图采取主动，在罗马权力的边界之外去迎战并消灭条顿人和辛布里人。因为这些野蛮人就在高卢四处游荡，进行着掠夺、洗劫、杀戮之类的勾当。而罗马人不断前去试图攻击他们，却又不断被打败。先是在公元前109年，接着在两年后今天的波尔多附近。其中一位执政官在那场战役中战死，另一位则被逼入绝境，他唯一能让自己脱身的方法，就是同意自己和军队从
the yoke. Oh my god. Yeah, ultimate humiliation. You put up, you know, two spears and put another spear across it and everyone has to symbolically bend and crawl and, well, not symbolically. I mean, You literally do it, but it's obviously a symbol of humiliation. So that's very bad. And then I had forgotten the full details of this defeat. So it happens in 105. And it's a culminating disaster in the Roman attempts to stop the barbarians. It happens outside Arousio, which is the town in Southern Gaul, which gives its name
轭下钻过去。哦，天哪。是的，终极羞辱。你竖起两根长矛，上面再横放一根长矛，每个人都必须象征性地弯腰爬过去，好吧，其实也不是象征性。我的意思是，你真的得这么做，但这显然是羞辱的象征。所以这非常糟糕。然后我忘记了这场惨败的全部细节。它发生在公元前105年。这是罗马试图阻止野蛮人行动的灾难性顶峰。它发生在阿劳西奥城外，这是南部高卢的一座城镇，它的名字来源于
to Orange. So ultimately, to the Orange Order. I mean, that's an amazing thought. And in this battle, the Romans, it said, lose over 100,000 men, which is more than they lose in at Can I. Is that plausible, really, that they lost that many? I mean, these figures are all made up, aren't they really? I don't think they're made up.
奥兰治。归根结底，就是奥兰治派的那个奥兰治。我的意思是，这是一个惊人的想法。在这场战役中，据说罗马人损失了超过10万人，这比他们在坎尼战役中损失的人数还要多。这真的合理吗，他们真的损失了这么多人吗？我的意思是，这些数字都是编造出来的，对吧？我不认为这是编造的。
It's clearly a massive defeat. And yet it's barely remembered. And you think how much it's written about Can I and the impact that it had on the Romans. At the time, it must have just seemed overwhelming. It must have seemed a disaster on par with that. and when the news of it is brought to Rome, there is this terrible mood of panic. So thank you very much for listening to that. And if you liked it and you would like to hear more, then you can find the full episode at the rest is history.com.
这显然是一场惨败。然而它却几乎没有被人记住。想想人们对坎尼战役写了多少，以及它对罗马人产生了多大的影响。当时，这一定让人觉得难以承受。这一定是一场堪比坎尼的灾难。当这个消息传到罗马时，弥漫着一种可怕的恐慌情绪。非常感谢大家收听这段内容。如果你喜欢它，并想听更多，那么你可以在therestishistory.com找到完整版的节目。
Hi everybody, Dominic again. Now here is the clip that we promised to you from our show The Book Club, which talks about Ernest Hemingway's book for whom the bell tolls, and specifically the history of the Spanish Civil War. So Spain has not been involved in the First World War at all. It's been a backwater, basically. It's been really politically turbulent. There is a king. It's normally a parliamentary system. Most of Spain is untouched by the modern world. So it feels like these huge estates called the Latifundiae, which go back to the Roman period. I found this extraordinary. I had no idea until I started reading up for the session. Well, this is true of Spain and Portugal, actually. They would have absolutely gigantic rural estate. It's run by landowners, almost a kind of feudal system.
大家好，我是多米尼克。现在播放的是我们向大家承诺过的来自节目《读书俱乐部》的片段，其中讨论了欧内斯特·海明威的书《丧钟为谁而鸣》，特别是西班牙内战的历史。所以西班牙根本没有卷入第一次世界大战。它基本上是一个边陲之地。它的政治一直很动荡。那里有一个国王。它通常是一个议会制国家。西班牙大部分地区都没有受到现代世界的影响。所以感觉就像那些被称为大庄园的巨大地产，可以追溯到罗马时期。我觉得这太不可思议了。在开始为这次会议做准备之前，我一无所知。嗯，西班牙和葡萄牙确实都是如此。它们拥有绝对巨大的农村庄园。由地主经营，几乎是一种封建制度。
The peasants are enthralled to the landowner and to the church and whatnot. There are parts of Spain that have industrialized, the Basque Country, the North, and Catalonia. But those are obviously places with separatist movements. So Spain feels very fractured. And there's lots of labor unrest. There's a big anarchist movement. There was a socialist movement. There's a communist party.
农民依附于地主、教会等等。西班牙有一些地方实现了工业化，比如巴斯克地区、北部和加泰罗尼亚。但这些显然都是存在分裂主义运动的地方。所以西班牙感觉非常分裂。并且有很多劳工动乱。有一个庞大的无政府主义运动。还有一个社会主义运动。有一个共产党。
In the 20s, there was a coup. and a general took power called General Miguel Primo de Rivera, you know, under the king. But that didn't really work out. They brought back democracy at the beginning of the 1930s, but it's incredibly polarized and unstable between right and left. There are terrible strikes. So, for example, in the north in 1935, there are assassinations, there are kind of paramilitary movements and whatnot.
在20年代，发生了一场政变，一位名叫米格尔·普里莫·德里维拉的将军在国王手下夺取了政权。但这并没有真正成功。他们在20世纪30年代初恢复了民主，但在左翼和右翼之间，政局变得极其极化和不稳定。这里发生了可怕的罢工。例如，在1935年的北部，发生了暗杀事件，还有各种准军事运动等等。
The son of the previous dictator, Primo de Rivera, sets up a little fascist party called the Falange, which actually sort of gives its name, really, to, it's then co-opted by the right, by the conservatives who win the Spanish Civil War. I mean, whether they're really fascists or whether they're just basically using the fascist label is an interesting question. Right, so it all comes to head in 1936. There's an election at the beginning of the year, which means that a popular front, which is a kind of left-wing alliance of liberals, socialists, you know, sort of left-wing
前独裁者普里莫·德里维拉的儿子建立了一个名为“长枪党”的小型法西斯政党，这个党派实际上为赢得西班牙内战的右翼保守派所吸纳并借用了名号。我的意思是，他们究竟是真正的法西斯分子，还是基本上只是在借用“法西斯”这个标签，这是一个有趣的问题。好吧，这一切在1936年达到了白热化。年初举行了一场选举，这意味着人民阵线——这是一种由自由主义者、社会主义者、左翼政党等组成的左翼联盟——
parties. Some of the separatists, or more nationalist groups from the areas like the Basque Country or Catalonia, they come to power. And there's a lot of social unrest because they want to push through radical changes and the right don't like that. And in July 1936, the army launches, right-wing elements within the army launch a coup. The reason the Spanish Civil War happens is the coup doesn't fully work. So basically, the trade unions, the big cities in Madrid, Barcelona and so on, stay loyal to the elected government. So Spain is divided between the rebels, the coup people in the army,
以及来自巴斯克地区或加泰罗尼亚等地区的一些分离主义者或民族主义团体上台了。社会动荡不安，因为他们想要强行推行激进的变革，而右翼对此非常不满。1936年7月，军队发动了政变，军队内部的右翼势力发动了政变。西班牙内战爆发的原因是政变并没有完全成功。基本上，工会、马德里、巴塞罗那等大城市仍然忠于民选政府。所以西班牙分裂为两部分：叛军、军队中的政变策划者，
and their allies who are often like big landowners, the Catholic Church and so on, who want to defend the status quo. They've got half the country, often kind of rural areas, more conservative and so on. But the big cities and Catalonia and so on, so Madrid, Barcelona, places like that, they stay loyal to the elected government.
以及他们的盟友（通常如大地主、天主教会等），他们想要捍卫现状。他们占据了半个国家，通常是农村地区，较为保守等等。但是大城市、加泰罗尼亚等地，比如马德里、巴塞罗那之类的地方，则效忠于民选政府。
So on the one hand, you have what are called the nationalists, And these are the forces of the right, the army, the coup plotters and so on. Effectively, from day one, they have very, very strong international backing from Mussolini in Italy and then Hitler in Germany. And then on the left, you have the elected government, who are the Republicans, and they get help eventually from the Soviet Union, which is something of a poison chalice. And they do appeal to Britain and France for help, but they don't really get it.
一方面，有所谓的国民军，这些是右翼力量、军队、政变策划者等等。实际上从第一天起，他们就得到了来自意大利墨索里尼和后来德国希特勒非常非常强烈的国际支持。而在左翼，则是民选政府，即共和派，他们最终得到了苏联的某种程度上带有毒苹果性质的援助。他们确实向英国和法国寻求帮助，但并没有真正得到。
And they have help from foreign volunteers. And this war becomes incredibly bitter and incredibly bloody. I mean, this is always the way with civil wars because people feel it's an existential struggle. The future of their country is at stake. They come to believe, you know, their neighbours, the people in the next town, the landowners or the priests or the anarchists or whoever are going to kill them and their families. They've got to kill them first. People, in some places, there are horrendous, horrendous, sadistic mass.
他们得到了外国志愿者的帮助。这场战争变得异常残酷和血腥。我的意思是，内战总是如此，因为人们觉得这是一场生死存亡的斗争。他们国家的未来危在旦夕。他们开始相信——你知道的，他们的邻居、隔壁镇的人、地主、神父、无政府主义者或随便什么人——将会杀死他们和他们的家人。他们必须先下手为强。在某些地方，发生了极其恐怖、极其虐待狂般的屠
and things. I think they found something like at the end of, maybe the start of the 21st century or something, that Spain had the highest number of mass graves after Cambodia. So if you want to hear the full episode, just go to Apple or Spotify or YouTube and search for The Book Club. And there it is. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
杀等事件。我想他们发现在21世纪初左右的时候，西班牙的乱葬岗数量仅次于柬埔寨，高居第二位。如果你想听完整版的节目，只需前往苹果、声田或油管搜索《读书俱乐部》。就在那里。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。